Eigentlich bilden kristalle regelmäßige strukturen
Im raum jetzt haben zwei forschungsgruppen aber kristalle erschaffen die
regelmäßige strukturen in der zeit haben das ist ziemlich verrückt und ein neuer
aggregatzustand gebildet wird er durch regelmäßige gitter doch diese
verändern ihrem zustand in regelmäßigen takt das klingt sehr nach science fiction und galt in der theorie
tatsächlich lange als unmöglich welche anwendungen könnten uns also dieser neuer materiezustand
ermöglichen und machen diese zeit kristalle bald sogar zeitreisen möglich ihr habt euch dieses thema bei whatsapp messenger
gewünscht und bekommt jetzt alle wichtigen facts zum thema herzlich willkommen bei pixum science fiction
Übrigens haben wir jetzt auch den facebook messenger instagram und telegramm als messenger
Hinzugefügt also noch mehr möglichkeiten dabei zu sein alle infos gibt es am ende des videos
2012 hatte der amerikanische nobelpreisträger
Frank wilczek ein theoretisches modell aufgestellt in dem es um die existenz sogenannter zeit kristalle ging ihr wisst es vielleicht
Charakteristisch für kristalle sich beispielsweise diamanten ist dass ihre atome in
regelmäßigen dreidimensionalen gitterstrukturen angeordnet sind sie bilden quasi die grund einheiten der kristalle die sich
Im raum wiederholt bei zeit christan ist dies anders bei ihnen existieren solche sich wiederholenden diskreten zustände
im bezug auf die zeit
ihre bausteine ändern also periodisch ihren zustand und das ist wirklich ganz besonders stellt euch mal vor ihr bewegt euch durch
einen herkömmlichen kristall in immer gleichen abständen trifft man auf ein atom oder molekül
auch bei zeit kristallen ist die struktur wieder kennt aber eben in der zeit um
Im bild zu bleiben hier würde man sich nicht durch den raum bewegen sondern an einer stelle verharren und waren dabei würde man
beobachten dass sich die umgebung ständig ändert bis sie dann nach einer bestimmten zeitspanne wieder genauso aussieht wie am
Anfang selbst nachdem das theoretische modell des amerikanischen forscher veröffentlicht wurde galt was bei vielen wissenschaftlerinnen
wissenschaftlern als komplett unmöglich doch jetzt
existiert nicht nur mehr dieses theoretische modell zwei forschungsteams von den in harvard und princeton
haben solche zeit kristalle jetzt tatsächlich in die realität umgesetzt
Und das auf unterschiedliche art und weise das besondere bei beiden sie pulsieren im prinzip ohne
energiezufuhr vor sich her und das scheint zunächst einmal den gesetzen der physik zu
Widersprechen der ist jetzt zeit kristall besteht aus zehn etablierte millionen in die in einem elektrischen feld
schwebt laserpulse von außen lassen die spins also quasi die einen eigenen drehimpuls der
teilchen umklappen und verhindern so dass das system ins gleichgewicht kommt an dieser stelle könnte man denken
Dass die ionen dem takt des lesers folgen aber genau das gegenteil war der fall
Die ep um ihnen bildeten eigene wechselwirkungen aus und klappt nur bei jedem zweiten
laserpuls um nach ansicht des forschungsteams bestätigt diese beobachtung
dass das system eine eigenständige und zeitlich
Diskretes struktur eingenommen hat ein zeit kristall also der zweite erschaffene zeit christa von der harvard university besteht aus einem synthetischen
diamanten in seinem kohlenstoff gitter sind eine million fehlstellen an diesen sogenannten stickstoff lücken lagert sich statt dem
kohlenstoffatom 1 stickstoff atom an mit hilfe von mikrowellen gelang es dem forschungsteam
Das in diesen lücken spins umgeklappt wurden doch auch hier entstand ein tag der doppelt so langsam war wie das
Wechseln muster des pins und so heißt es in der studie zitat dieses system bricht damit die zugrundeliegende zeitliche symmetrie
des pulses und bildet die diskrete ordnung eines zeit rist als
Beide experimente scheinen also tatsächlich zu belegen dass zeit kristalle existieren selbst wenn sie so lange als
unmöglichkeiten doch was bedeutet dieser neue materiezustand für unsere zukunft dazu eine der beteiligten forscherinnen des harvard teams medica
khemani, mit der schaffung der zeit kristalle haben wir eine neue
materiezustand geschaffen und so den katalog der möglichen ordnung in raum und zeit um einen eintrag erweitert
beispielsweise könnten daten in quantencomputer besser gegen störungen abgesichert werden denn laser manipulierte ionenfallen
in der diamanten werden als bauteile in quantencomputern
eingesetzt zudem könnte man mit zeit kristallen extrem schwache magnetfelder und niedrige temperaturen
einfacher messen doch selbst zu diesen ideen da steckt die forschung noch in den kinderschuhen und auch zeitreisen ja werden durch diesen neuen
Aggregatzustand nicht möglich werden schade wenn er als erstes neues dazu und zu allen anderen themen
erfahren wollt dann endet meine telefonnummer hier
Im messenger und das geht jetzt nicht nur bei uns sondern instagram facebook und telegramm sind auch dabei
Und dann erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen anderen vom neuesten video
Täglich garantiert ihr könnt doch direkt über mich in der redaktion von kriegs- und mitmachen und mitbestimmen was hierbei clixoom
Passiert und jetzt eben haben wir neben mord auch ins tram face book und den telekom messenger dabei und zur begrüßung gibt es
Noch ein kleines geschenk einfach hier draufklicken natürlich nicht das abo mit der
Genauen blogger vergessen und hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch. Draufklicken die genaueste und der welt ansonsten will ich mal sagen bis dann
bleibt dran